legends about the end of the world often
come with the sounds of thundering
hooves and the approach of four horsemen
war
famine pestilence
death they will descend on the world and
usher in the end of days it's a
terrifying idea these horsemen bringing
darkness and decay wherever they go as
the world collapses all around them we
all hope that we'll never see the day
that the four horsemen come
unfortunately some lucky people out
there have already encountered their own
version of the horsemen of the
apocalypse shadowy riders with inhuman
strength that follow disaster
destruction and untold suffering the scp
foundation came across a series of
journal entries written by dave harkin
an infantry men in the british
expeditionary force during world war one
that first world war was a nightmare for
all who fought in it a sea of bloodshed
and gunfire young men crouched terrified
in foxholes and wondering when death
would finally come for them the horrors
of war are notable but not exactly the
sort of thing the scp foundation
preoccupies itself with so what was so
captivating so specifically terrible
about dave harkin's journals they
described his experiences over the
course of the battle of the somme and an
anomaly he encountered there that was
unlike anything he had ever seen no
military training no combat experience
could have prepared him for what was
waiting hiding in the fog of war his
first journal entry began on a
lighthearted note or as lighthearted as
one can be in the face of combat june 27
1916
finally arrived at the front i picked up
this little journal while i was in paris
figured i might as well keep record of
my heroics on the battlefield quite
chuffed to finally be in action though
it seems i'm the only one most of these
blokes have been fighting for a couple
months now and they look downright
dreadful mud all over the uniform and
their faces are so pale look like they
haven't eaten or slept for months a few
days later he began to hear stirrings
amongst his fellow soldiers and strange
sounds that rocked their barracks he
described the first unsettling incident
july 2nd 1916 woke in the early hours of
the morning ground was shaking damn near
shook me out into the muck on the dugout
floor poor blokes in the bunks on the
other side looked like they had seen a
ghoul pair of northern irish lads from
kitchener's armies if i remember right
kept muttering about a knockety both
gripping a gold crucifix i was about to
lay my head back down and get a wink of
shut eye when i ended up scrambling into
the mud loudest damn thing i'd ever
heard thought it was the hun artillery
about to mark us with a whiz-bang only
problem was never did get the bang this
morning asked our brass ad about the
artillery barrage gave me a funny look
that's what the bloody hell i was
talking about the next day dave went
searching for the source of the loud
sound he didn't find any evidence of
artillery but instead found something he
had never seen before it was a crater
shaped like a giant horse's hoof he
brushed it off as just another oddity of
the battlefield a bit strange but
nothing to be concerned about there were
more important things at hand anyway the
next day he finally saw combat first
hand and things only got more bizarre
and frightening july 3rd 1916 huns made
a push today first time they've moved
into our region first time i'd ever seen
combat it's not romantic and adventurous
it's terrifying and deadly my hands
can't stop shaking already messed up the
[ __ ] once the huns had our outfitting up
against the wall damn near overran us
didn't help that it rained that night
before making our foxhole filled to the
brim with muck one of the fritz came
right at me just i put one right between
his eyes fell right at the edge of the
trench i had to look at him in the eyes
poor lad couldn't have been more than 17
or 18. martin one of the irish lads is
gone was unlike anything i'd ever seen
one moment he's standing shooting at
huns all of a sudden the mud starts
boiling for anyone can react mud just
flies everywhere everyone else is
suddenly knocked down off their feet i
look up and he's just gone wasn't even
body parts left haven't told anyone but
i'd swear that there were bones coming
from underneath him right before the mud
went flying his mate brendan was digging
in the mud for hours looking for the
crucifix martin's body was never found
no matter how they searched a little
over a week later things got even worse
july 14th and 15 1916 puns tried to push
this morning in the rain i was in the
machine gun nest with brendan the other
irish chap in my unit they kept coming
and coming and getting stuck in the mud
and i just kept shooting sun is rising
i'm on watch till at least eight at
least that's what the brass had said
i've started losing track of how much
time's been passing there's something
out there something lurking out in the
mud and dead huns nearly dozed off last
night listening to the moans of the
blighty wounded stuck out in no man's
land poor souls got left behind saw
something out of the edge of my vision
something big couldn't quite make it out
it was much darker than usual overcast
sky was obscuring the full moon heard a
couple of screams but whatever it was
was gone before my flare hit the sky
this would not be dave's last sighting
of the large dark figure this mysterious
shadow would appear again several days
later and there would be more of them
july 30th 1916 i've been seeing them at
the edge of my vision ever since that
first night they're huge they move so
damn fast that they're gone before i can
get a clear look or at least that's how
it was mucking out until today thick fog
and mist rolled in this morning
blanketed everything we figured the huns
might use it to launch another push
bastards have been pushing non-stop
since the 20th side through the fog
looked like a shadow hiding in the mist
some sort of horse-like creature with
something dragging along the ground and
a giant lump where the writer would sit
said the lumps started moving could've
sworn it was a person or something that
looked like a person sat up and the
things dragging along the ground reached
out in front of it and picked up
something thought it was a couple dead
jerry's until they started squirming
i'll never forget the noise it made
louder than a banshee shrill and twisted
it looked right at me two pairs of red
glowing orbs two weeks after meeting
eyes with this chilling apparition dave
wrote a short note in this journal
august 5th brendan calls them knock
leaves won't tell me much more than that
beginning to understand why all these
blokes look so terrified when i first
arrived it wasn't until another week
passed that dave would truly begin to
understand just what kind of monster he
was up against not the enemy soldiers
but something far more horrible
something inhuman august 13th bloody
hell the nightmares been on watch two
nights in a row one just appeared right
there right in front of me 20 feet had
to be at least 20 feet away towering
into the sky got my flare to go off in
time just to see it pick up a couple
wounded jerry's in the mud they don't
have bloody skin they're just muscle and
fat the thing on its back was inhuman no
way it could be human had no skin either
no legs just moved straight into the
horse at the stomach i took a couple
shots at it with my rifle did absolutely
nothing like i was shooting it with a
slingshot it stopped as my flare reached
its highest point and turned hooked
straight down at me both the horse and
the thing on its back it smiled he tried
to warn his superiors try to warn of the
horrors he was seeing and the danger he
felt they posed but they wouldn't listen
night after night the creatures came
back august 17 1916 been assigned night
watch the past four nights straight
tried to tell the brass hat about the
nook lives didn't believe me said it was
the shell shock playing with my head had
to put a sock in it and keep on it keeps
coming back every night same spot 20
feet in front of me picks up wounded
jerry's turns and looks and then it's
gone he plays with me i'm sure of it
last night there was another one too for
those things on its back did the same
damn thing a few days later dave spotted
something that made his blood run cold
7am august 20th 1916 jerry's made a big
push yesterday rained two days ago all
day so the muck was deep we were on the
machine gun again in the pillbox so many
of them in no man's land last night
couldn't tell the dead from the living
haven't slept in six days there were
five tonight three of them had more than
one of those things on their back the
one that keeps coming back dropped
something saw it shine in the flare
light 10 am august 20th 1916 went out
into the mud where it appears every
night found martin's crucifix and tin
hat whatever this thing was it had taken
martin it seemed to want dave to know
that too it left behind martin's lost
things for him to find as if it was
gloating as if it already knew that it
had won august 20th 1916 the getting
bold saw one out in broad daylight
pretty sure it was the same one buried
itself in the mud just lying there
waiting we're going over the top at
three there are more out there now while
doing the same thing god help us dave
harkland was declared missing in action
on august 20th 1916 following an
attempted counter-attack against the
german forces another soldier from his
unit brendan o'malley was also reported
missing in action on the same day though
dave's body was never recovered his
journal was found 20 feet away from the
edge of the german trenches two months
later poor dave harkin had no idea what
he and the rest of his fellow soldiers
encountered out there he didn't live to
learn more but he came face to face with
scp-3456
scp-3456 is not one being but rather a
group of quadrupeds that vaguely
resemble horses from a distance their
silhouette looks like that of a horse
with a human riding on its back however
once the observer gets closer they will
notice some disturbing differences these
creatures do not look like any ordinary
horse they are smooth and hairless with
translucent skin and three-toed hose
anyone unfortunate enough to get close
to one of these creatures will be able
to see through their skin to the blood
vessels and muscle underneath they will
also notice that there is no rider
perched atop the creatures back at all
the humanoid shape is part of the
creature's body an extension of them
fused to its back the humanoid figure
consists of a pair of long arms which
drags along the ground as the creature
moves and ahead the arms end in
sharpened bones rather than fingers and
the head has mostly human features with
the exception of a hole where the nose
should be the creatures vary greatly in
size with the largest on record
measuring at a height of 30 meters and a
width of 15. they appear to be
invulnerable at least when it comes to
any traditional human weaponry they have
currently been exposed to gunfire
explosives swords and arrows and even
nuclear blasts seem to have no effect if
you happen to get a good look at one of
these bulletproof abominations in person
then i am so sorry you are as good as
gone because once you have seen one of
these creatures they have also seen you
and they will not stop until they have
taken you they will track you stalk you
hide buried in mud and nestled in bushes
they will wait for the opportune moment
and they will reach out with their
unnaturally long arms smiling with no
lips as their blood-red eyes burn like
hellfire and you will disappear forever
they will travel far beyond the site
where they first appeared until they
have finally captured their prey this
isn't an scp-096 situation either they
aren't punishing you for seeing their
face they want to be seen and will go
out of their way to show themselves to
people until they have captured as many
as they want no one knows what becomes
of
scp-3456's victims but they are never
seen again though items once belonging
to the missing people may resurface
their bodies are never found there is
only one way to escape from scp-3456
and that is to find and cross a body of
fresh water for reasons unknown the
entities are unable or unwilling to
cross rivers streams and lakes the
foundation first discovered this during
an operation in iraq in which several
agents encountered a group of
scp-3456 manifestations they fled from
the monsters and quickly retreated
across the tigris river once they had
reached the other side they saw that the
creatures had not followed them onto the
bridge instead they remained at the
riverbank on the other side watching and
waiting this was quickly noted and added
to potential containment procedures
though the exact reason for
scp-3456's dislike of fresh water is
currently unknown in dave harkland's
journals his fellow soldier described
the creatures as knuckles but would not
elaborate beyond that so what is a
knuckle the word refers to a creature
from the waters of orkney a group of
islands on the northern coast of
scotland their name is thought to come
from an orcidian word meaning devil of
the sea and they truly are like
something out of hell these creatures
are native to the ocean and supposedly
take on another form when in their
natural habitat
but no one knows what they truly look
like on land the creature is a hybrid of
a man and horse with a large snout like
that of a pig and a single red eye that
burns like the embers of a fire it has
no hair or skin
just raw tissue and bone dripping black
blood everything about the creature is
malicious and deadly intended to bring
harm and calamity to humans even its
breath is toxic thought to cause disease
plague and the death of crops as they
are native to the ocean they detest
fresh water and will not cross it even
in pursuit of their prey they will also
not appear when it is raining in the
legends of the knuckle they do have a
natural enemy a creature from arcadian
folklore known as the mithra of the sea
is said to have the power to keep the
monsters from coming ashore during the
summer months the mithra or mother is a
benevolent force of nature giving warmth
to the oceans and life to the beings on
the water and the land though
scp-3456 has appeared during the summer
months it has never been spotted in the
orkney region during this time of year
perhaps this is a coincidence but some
foundation researchers have proposed a
research expedition to the area in order
to look for the kindly ocean spirit so
far this proposal has been denied
scp-3456 is classified as ketter and
there is currently no way to effectively
contain it all previous attempts to
contain or to neutralize the horsemen
have failed though the foundation is
always looking for new methods to
attempt currently any personnel who see
the horsemen will be given class gmd
sticks at a treatment center located
within one kilometer of a freshwater
stream river or lake all references to
the horsemen have been scrubbed from
historical records and any sightings are
to be blamed on ptsd shock and
trauma-induced hysteria areas that are
likely to attract scp-3456
such as war zones and areas impacted by
natural disasters are to be heavily
monitored by the foundation in the event
of a disaster foundation personnel will
be sent to help with evacuation in order
to get all civilians away from scp-3456
as quickly as possible so what is
scp-3456
is it the dreaded nuclear from folk
tales and whispered fireside warnings
there are some notable differences
between the stories and what the
foundation encountered
scp-3456 does not seem to have come from
the ocean nor is it limited to only
appearing around orkney these beasts
seem to manifest from thin air and
disappear the same way when their nasty
work is done but folklore and passing
down stories often distorts things
details change and others are added or
left out in the original stories the
knuckles were thought to be the cause of
famines plagues and disasters perhaps it
was simply drawn to these events lured
there by the scent of pure human misery
perhaps the nuclear is not just similar
to
scp-3456 but the two are one and the
same or perhaps they are something
entirely different whatever the case may
be there is nothing we can do to stop
them
war famine pestilence and death are
everywhere they are inevitable and
unfortunate parts of life on earth so it
seems are these deadly writers these
monsters that are neither horse nor man
but still somehow both every time we
wage war every time disaster strikes
they will come to watch to pick through
the rubble and to smile maybe we don't
need to dread the coming of the horsemen
of the apocalypse they
are already here now go check out waldo
finds you
scp-4885 find him and the secret at the
bottom of scp-087 explain for more
monstrous finds from the scp foundation